who's that sliding into your Twitter DMS
is it the federal government
well according to Elon Musk government
bureaucrats were routinely taking a
close look at users content here's what
Elon told Fox News as Tucker Carlson the
degree to which a various government
agencies had effectively had full access
to everything that was going on on
Twitter blew my mind I was not aware of
that would that include people's DMs
uh yes unsurprising the feds sure loved
to invoke National Security then take
away more of your rights and pretend
they're keeping you safe well guess
they're at it again following a massive
leak of U.S intelligence documents that
were posted on Discord the Biden
Administration wants more power to
monitor online chat rooms a senior
Administration official told NBC news
that the government quote is now looking
at expanding the universe of online
sites that law enforcement authorities
track what's bad because it leads to
more government surveillance of the
American people and eventually more
censorship of political speech so let's
keep the government out of our chat
rooms and watch out for your DMs